THE FORCES HAVE SUFFERED TWO
CASUALTIES AS A RESULT OF ENEMY
FIRE ALONG THE FRONT LINES.
>> LIVE TO KYIV AND BRING IN CNN
CHIEF INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT CLARISSA WARD.
A LOT OF NEW INFORMATION THIS
MORNING AND YOU HAVE BEEN TO AND
FROM ALREADY WHAT MIGHT BE THE
BIGGEST HOT SPOT, THE MOST TENSE
AREA IN THE ENTIRE NATION.
>> SO, JOHN, THESE FRONT LINES
BETWEEN THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY
AND RUSSIAN-BACKED SEPARATISTS
IN THE FAR EAST OF THE COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN LARGELY FROZEN FOR
YEARS.
THE WAR HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
EIGHT YEARS, BUT THEY HAVE BEEN
LARGELY FROZEN.
UP UNTIL REALLY THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS, WHERE WE STARTED TO SEE
A MAJOR UPTICK, PARTICULARLY
YESTERDAY, HEAVY SHELLING IN ONE
TOWN, THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY
TOOK US THERE, IN DARK, WHICH IS
VERY UNUSUAL FOR THEM, THEY
WANTED TO SHOW THE WORLD WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
TAKE A LOOK.
UKRAINIAN MILITARY HAS BROUGHT
US NEARLY 400 MILES TOWARDS THE
FRONT LINES IN THE EAST OF THE
COUNTRY.
IT IS ALREADY DARK BY THE TIME
WE LAND.
WE ONLY HAVE A SHORT TIME ON THE
GROUND, BUT THEY ARE DETERMINED
TO SHOW US THE AFTERMATH OF
HEAVY SHELLING EARLIER IN THE
DAY.
THIS KINDERGARTEN IS LESS THAN
THREE MILES FROM THE SO-CALLED
LINE OF CONTACT, THE FRONT LINE.
AND WITNESSES IN THIS AREA SAID
THAT AROUND 8:00 OR 9:00 THIS
MORNING, THEY STARTED TO HEAR
SHELLING.
IT WAS LOUD ENOUGH THEY COULD
HEAR THE WHISTLE OF THE SHELLS
GOING BY AND TWO OF THEM LANDED
HERE AT THIS KINDERGARTEN.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
AT THE END OF THE HALLWAY, THIS
IS WHAT REMAINS OF THE PLAY
ROOM.
THE MILITARY SAYS THE FIRST
SHELL HIT AT 8:45.
MERCIFULLY THE CHILDREN WERE
EATING BREAKFAST IN ANOTHER PART
OF THE BUILDING.
THE TEACHER TELLS ME SHE
IMMEDIATELY RUSHED THEM INTO THE
HALLWAY, AWAY FROM THE WINDOWS.
SO SHE'S SAYING IN THAT MOMENT
SHE WAS ONLY REALLY AFRAID FOR
THE CHILDREN.
I ASKED HER HOW THEY REACTED TO
THE SITUATION.
OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN THOUGHT
IT WAS ALL A GAME AT FIRST, AND
WE LET THEM PRETEND, THEY SELLS
US.
OUR OLDER CHILDREN UNDERSTOOD
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND THEY WERE
AFRAID.
VIDEO RELEASED BY UKRAINIAN
POLICE SHOWS THE KIDS BEING
HASTILY EVACUATED FROM THE
BUILDING.
OBVIOUSLY IT IS VERY DARK HERE.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU CAN SEE,
THIS IS ACTUALLY A CHILDREN'S
PLAYGROUND.
IF YOU TURN OVER HERE, YOU CAN
SEE THIS IS A CRATER AND THE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE TELLING US
THAT THIS IS WHERE THE OTHER
SHELL HIT.
OUR TIME ON THE GROUND IS
RESTRICTED.
FIGHTING USUALLY BEGINS AFTER
DARK HERE.
AS WE FINISH UP A LIVE SHOT, OUR
UKRAINIAN MINDERS GROW NERVOUS.
YES, I HEAR IT.
>> LET'S GO.
>> Reporter: JOHN, PLEASE EXCUSE
ME, OUR UKRAINIAN MILITARY
MINDERS ARE ASKING US TO MOVE
BECAUSE OF THAT SHELLING.
WE'LL CHECK IN WITH YOU AS SOON
AS WE CAN.
THANK YOU.
>> LET'S GO.
>> Reporter: ON AN AVERAGE DAY
THERE MIGHT BE THREE OR FOUR
MAJOR CEASE-FIRE VIOLATIONS
AROUND HERE.
TODAY, THE MILITARY SAYS THERE
HAVE BEEN MORE THAN 30.
>> LET'S GO, GUYS.
>> Reporter: THEY'RE TELLING US
WE HAVE TO GO NOW.
IT IS A STEADY STREAM OF
ARTILLERY WE CAN HEAR IN THE
DIFFERENCE.
WE'RE GETTING ON TO THE BUS TO
LEAVE.
IN THE HOURS AFTER WE LEAVE,
ANOTHER SHELL HITS A HOUSE IN
THE SAME TOWN.
AS THIS FRONT LINE CONTINUES TO
HEAT UP AT A TIME WHEN CALM IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED.
NOW, I SHOULD SAY, JOHN, THAT
PEOPLE IN THOSE SEPARATIST AREAS
HAVE ALSO BEEN REPORTING AN
UPTICK IN SHELLING COMING INTO
THEIR AREAS FROM THE UKRAINIAN
SIDE.
CNN HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM THOSE
CLAIMS, BUT WHAT THIS ESCALATION
REALLY AMOUNTS TO OR WHAT THE
CONCERN IS THAT IT COULD PROVIDE
SOME KIND OF A PRETEXT FOR
PRESIDENT PUTIN THEN TO LAUNCH
SOME KIND OF MILITARY
INTERVENTION TO PROTECT PEOPLE
IN THOSE SEPARATIST AREAS.
MANY OF WHOM, ROUGHLY 600,000 OF
WHOM CARRY RUSSIAN PASSPORTS,
JOHN, BRIANNA?
>> SPEAKING TO YOU A FEW HOURS
AGO AND AGAIN THIS MORNING, ONE
THING I'M LEFT WITH IS YOU THINK
THIS FEELS DIFFERENT AND
DECIDEDLY LOOKS DIFFERENT THAN
IT HAS.
YES, THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
EIGHT YEARS, BUT NOW THEY
ENTERED A NEW PHASE.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS HAS BEEN,
WELL, IF VLADIMIR PUTIN DOESN'T
INVADE FURTHER TODAY, MAYBE HE
JUST KEEPS THIS POSTURE UP FOR
WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS.
BUT THIS LEVEL OF TENSION, THIS
LEVEL OF VIOLENCE, HOW
SUSTAINABLE IS THAT?
>> Reporter: THIS IS ALWAYS THE
WORRY, RIGHT?
IT MAY BE THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
HAS ALREADY ACHIEVED HIS
OBJECTIVE, THAT HE'S ALREADY
DESTABILIZING UKRAINE BY HAVING
TENSIONS AT THIS LEVEL.
BUT ONCE YOU HAVE SIGNIFICANT
ACTIVITY TAKING PLACE ON FRONT
LINES THAT AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
HAVE BEEN LARGELY QUIET FOR MANY
YEARS NOW, YOU ARE DRAMATICALLY
ESCALATING THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THIS COULD DEVOLVE INTO
SOMETHING VERY, VERY DIFFERENT
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS SUCH A
DANGEROUS INFLEXION POINT AND
WHY IT DOES FEEL A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
I DON'T WANT TO OVERSTATE IT,
JOHN, THERE HAVE BEEN CEASE-FIRE
VIOLATIONS ON A DAILY BASIS FOR
SOME TIME.
WE VISITED THE FRONT LINE
BEFORE, JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO, AND WE HEARD A GRENADE, YOU
KNOW, LAND ABOUT 200, 300 FEET
AWAY FROM US.
IT WAS RIGHT ON THE FRONT LINE.
THIS IS SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT OR IT
FELT SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A JOURNALIST ON
THE GROUND, NEARLY THREE MILES
AWAY FROM THE FRONT LINE,
HITTING A KINDERGARTEN, ALSO
HITTING A HOUSE, I DON'T WANT TO
TRY TO IMPLY THAT THOSE WERE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AS
CIVILIAN STRUCTURES, BUT
CERTAINLY IT DOES RAISE THE
SPECTER AS I MENTIONED BEFORE OF
THINGS GETTING OUT OF CONTROL
AND THAT'S THE REAL FEAR HERE,
JOHN.
>> WHEN UKRAINE KNOWS THAT THE
RUSSIANS COULD BE PLOTTING A
FALSE FLAG INCIDENT, A FAKE
INCIDENT THAT WOULD REQUIRE
RUSSIA TO RESPOND IN THEORY,
DOES THIS PUT EVEN MORE PRESSURE
ON UKRAINE TO SHOW RESTRAINT,
HOW DID THEY TRY TO THREAD THAT
NEEDLE?
>> SO, YOU KNOW, RUSSIA IS VERY
WELL KNOWN FOR IMPLEMENTING
SOMETHING CALLED PROVOCATIONS
WHICH THEN DRAW PEOPLE INTO A
BLOODY CONFLICT.
AND SO, YES, NOW UKRAINE IS PUT
IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE
SEEING SHELLS LANDING ON
CIVILIAN STRUCTURES, LIKE
KINDERGARTENS, HOW DO THEY
RESPOND?
IF THEY RESPOND FORCEFULLY, THEY
VERY MUCH RUN THE RISK OF
FALLING IN TO THE PLANS,
POTENTIALLY, OF THE RUSSIAN
SIDE.
AND SO THAT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THEY ALSO HAVE
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES.
SO, IT BECOMES VERY COMPLEX TO
KNOW HOW TO RESPOND FOR
UKRAINIAN FORCES IN THAT
SITUATION.
AND EVEN MORE SO BECAUSE THOSE
ENTIRE AREAS BY THE FRONT LINES
UNDER THE MINSK ACCORDS, THESE
SORT OF PEACE AGREEMENTS TO HELP
STOP THE VIOLENCE ON THOSE FRONT
LINES, ARE SUPPOSED TO BE QUIET.
THERE ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
HEAVY WEAPONS USED THERE AS ALL.
THERE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PULLED
RIGHT BACK.
SO YOU GET INTO A SITUATION
WHERE THAT COULD QUICKLY BE
JEOPARDIZED, POTENTIALLY, JOHN.
>> CLARISSA WARD TAKING US TO
THE FRONT LINES AND BACK AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
REPORT.
>>> SECRETARY OF STATE TONY
BLINKEN WARNED THE UNITED
NATIONS YESTERDAY THAT RUSSIA
MIGHT JUSTIFY MILITARY ACTION
AGAINST UKRAINE WITH A STAGED
ATTACK.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> IT COULD BE A FABRICATED
SO-CALLED TERRORIST BOMBING
INSIDE RUSSIA.
THE INVENTED DISCOVERY OF THE
MASS GRAVE, A STAGED DRONE
STRIKE AGAINST CIVILIANS, OR A
FAKE, EVEN A REAL ATTACK USING
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
RUSSIA MAY DESCRIBE THIS EVENT
AS ETHNIC CLEANSING, OR A
GENOCIDE, MAKING A MOCKERY OF A
CONCEPT THAT WE IN THIS CHAMBER
DO NOT TAKE LIGHTLY.
>> JOINING US NOW IS DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR BEN CARDIN OF MARYLAND,
HE SERVES ON THE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE, ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION ON
SECURITY AND COOPERATION IN
EUROPE.
SIR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US.
I JUST WONDER, YOU SAW THIS
REPORT FROM OUR CLARISSA WARD
ABOUT THIS SHELLING OF THIS
KINDERGARTEN, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> WELL, BRIANNA, IT IS AN
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS SITUATION.
WE NOW SEE THE PROVOCATIONS
BEING INSTITUTED BY RUSSIA, WE
KNOW THE TROOP LEVELS THAT ARE
ON THE BORDER THAT COULD EASILY
INCUR INTO UKRAINE AT ANY TIME,
WE KNOW MR. PUTIN'S DESIRES, WE
HAVE U.S. INTELLIGENCE AND
GLOBAL INTELLIGENCE TO SHOW HE
IS DETERMINED TO DO SOMETHING IN
REGARDS TO THE INDEPENDENCE OF
UKRAINE.
IT IS AN EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS PLAY OUT
BEFORE IN GEORGIA, WHERE
RUSSIA'S PROVOCATION WAS USED